so many people had to wear a mask
whether they were on a plane whether
they were in certain public facilities
to hear that they only work at the
margins maybe 10 would make a lot of
people ask okay then why was I wearing a
mask for so many times we got to be
careful because if you read very
carefully what I said if you look at the
broad Public Health effect when you have
masks that a so-called mandated is
supposed to be worn because so many
people don't wear them even though
they're in an arena in which masks are
supposed to be worn or they don't wear
them properly from a public health
standpoint on the cohort of people the
effect can be only marginal and as we
mentioned it was 10 13 percent or so but
for the individual who religiously wears
a properly fitted mask the effect is
much much much better than that